so we're going to talk about sustainable
food supply and the role of food in
sustainability management you know one
of the points that I've been making that
this course makes that the program
actually makes is that when we think
about manager we have to think about the
physical dimensions of sustainability
after remember that we are biological
creatures so we need food and air and
water or we don't exist so this is an
important thing to keep in mind that
there are challenges to a sustainable
food system that we are now facing the
case studies that we looked at today
provided some examples of that we'll
talk about financing sustainable food
organizing and managing a sustainable
food supply and the role of government
and public policy and setting up a
framework as I mentioned to you that my
students in the environmental science
and policy program last semester did a
project for the mayor's office on where
new york city gets its food because
they're thinking in the next New York
City plan NYC 2030 to actually include
food sustainability as one of the issues
that they focus on it wasn't in the
first plan but it occurred to the people
doing the planning that we need parks
and we need to adapt to climate change
we need water we need fresh air but we
probably also need food now New Yorkers
have an incredible array of food choices
and we actually have a very vibrant
system of food supply on delivery and
consumption in New York many many
different varieties of food and a huge
market in fact one of the questions that
I was concerned about was since we don't
grow any food nearby or at least in the
city are we what happens if the food was
interrupted you know we what happens if
the water's interrupted if the
electricity is interrupted those are
things we've thought about but what
about the food well it turns out our
food supply system is probably the most
phenomenal example of pure capitalism at
work that you could imagine
every major restaurant or food retailer
they can't find something from one
supplier strawberries out of season
there's five other suppliers that are
ready to sell them maybe at a higher
price but it's a very very aggressive
and competitive system and I I thought
that was interesting I hadn't really
thought about it in those terms but it
makes a certain amount of sense the
other thing that my student was found
out was that one of the major costs of
the food system in New York City is the
cost of parking tickets every
distributor of food complained about it
and talked about that being up to five
percent of their cost of doing business
in New York so we're all paying a little
tax on that and one way or the other so
let's talk about the role of food supply
and sustainability management our urban
world is increasingly dependent on
industrial agriculture for survival I
asked the fellow that used to run the
mayor sustainability office I saw all
these green markets all over the city to
say this is great you know can we get
some more of these and he said well I
wish we could but we're out of farms
every farmer within 150 miles of new
york city is selling everything they can
grow at the green markets are to the
local restaurants that are specializing
on local foods it's a fad but it's more
than that it's it's also a thriving
market and in fact there's limits to how
much of that you can have within a close
range of New York City because the land
is more valuable for living on then
growing things on the closer you are to
the center of New York City the more
expensive the land is these days so
that's the problem we need these food
food factories to survive in developed
countries industrial agriculture is a
really good way of producing large
quantities of food so here's some data
since nineteen sixty milk production has
doubled meat production has tripled egg
production has quadrupled us factory
farming in 2004 provided 3900 calorie
per person per day exceeding demand by a
thousand calories per person per day so
we have an incredibly effective and
productive industrial food system in
this country now while industrial
farming feeds a lot of people and
provides lots of calories it has a lot
of negative environmental impacts the
biggest problem is industrial farms rely
on unsustainable resources that will
eventually be depleted if we're not
careful fossil fuels fresh water arable
land now the land and the water can
certainly be recycled and reused but the
fossil fuels obviously can't now I think
that the planet is capable of growing
sufficient food for the 7 billion people
here now and the 10 billion people that
will probably have before we peak but we
have to figure out a way to make
industrial agriculture more sustainable
we have to figure out better ways of
managing these farms and their impacts
we have to actually start building a
sustainable worldwide agriculture system
now we don't really know how to do that
yet but we're learning very very quickly
and I should say that agriculture is one
place where there's a lot of adaptation
and learning all of these modern
techniques of farming have grown up over
the last several hundred years with
rapid infusion of new technologies on a
regular basis it's really a remarkable
story of organisations changing that
small family farm that exists in
mythology these days in the United
States was really the way we farm and
it's been completely transformed into a
different kind of industry there are
some challenges to a sustainable food
system and I want to talk about those
the food system is characterized by a
number of environmentally destructive
practices the first of course is massive
overuse of pesticides and herbicides
pesticides are a very easy and low-cost
way of ensuring the crops don't get
eaten by pests though that's part of how
we manage our farms on the other hand
when if these pesticides
and herbicides are overused they leach
into the nearby streams they wash off
the farms and they can pollute water
they can also contaminate the ground
itself and they can deplete some of the
resources in the ground that contribute
to the life of the plants fertilizers
also contaminate freshwater supplies
where they're high nutrient of
quantities lead to the kind of phenomena
you see with lily pads growing in a pond
or when you see the growth of too much
vegetation in in and around waterways
that's often because those waterways are
being overfed buy fertilizer nutrients
so we have to advance the technology of
fertilizer content and application we
have to make sure through more efficient
and more effective uses of fertilizers
that it all gets absorbed by the plant
and goes into the plant instead of
spread all over the environment those
are and and part of that and this is
where genetically engineered plants
comes in which some people are against
but you can genetically engineer the
plant to be a better absorber of the
fertilizer and this is you know again
this idea that somehow we shouldn't be
doing this stuff is is really an
obstacle to progress although I should
say that the farming industry isn't
paying a whole lot of attention that
they're doing it anyway because they
they're doing it to reduce costs they
know if they can create a more efficient
plant it's a more profitable plant now
sometimes we don't like the way it
tastes and that's a problem for them
then they work on the taste issues but
all of this engineering is going on all
of the time another challenge to
industrial agriculture is poor
irrigation practice we talked a little
bit about that when we're talking about
water it can create the problem salt
water intrusion into the water table
which can ruin a water source it can
also if the irrigation system gets open
to contamination from pesticides and
herbicides and fertilizer it can
actually be a way to transport waste
throughout the hydrological system and
create problems in people's drinking
water so that's one set of
problems the other set of problems is
the conversion of forest pastures and
croplands that the the balance of local
ecology requires a certain amount of
different kinds of use and then you also
have this problem of monocultures where
the most profitable plant to grow is one
thing but that then leaves you open to
attack from parts of the ecology that
that will become a predator for that
particular plant and then you leave
yourself vulnerable to the destruction
of both your farm its production and the
environment surrounding it so some of
these issues are amenable to more
intelligent planning and knowledge and
thinking through of what is necessary to
maintain the ongoing production of the
plant this issue of monocultures can be
a real devastating one you know we saw
small examples of that here in New York
City something called the Dutch elm
disease where the Dutch elm became a
very popular tree got planted all over
New York and as well as a lot of
northeastern cities and then there was a
blight that started to attack the Dutch
Elam's and suddenly because we had a
monoculture there were no trees ins and
neighborhoods and we've learned now to
vary the street trees and the trees that
we plant in our part because of that the
question is can industrial farming adopt
the tailored and fine-tuned approach
seen in other types of manufacturing in
other words if you're manufacturing an
ipod or computer you have high-tech
micro technology working on production
processes at a very fine-grained level
agriculture will need some of the same
kinds of thinking to prevent impacts on
the environment okay so the question is
can that be done and can sustainability
be a goal along with high yield and
enhanced profit there's right now the
industrial farming industry wants to
make sure that they get lots of yield
and they're making the right stuff that
generates what the marketplace wants and
they make a lot of money those are some
of their goals could we add
sustainability
as a goal for industrial agriculture I
think it can be done but that's where
government is going to come in it's not
going to happen to the marketplace alone
we're gonna have to figure out ways of
adding a dimension of regulation to this
so that farms industrial farms are
required to think through some of these
practices so let me talk a little bit
about financing the farm business is a
high-risk business farming's high risk
because it's at the mercy of a lot of
uncontrollable factors what are those
factors well first of all this weather
you might have a drought you might have
a freeze you might have a flood you
might have too much wind at the wrong
time of year and all of those kinds of
things you could have pestis you could
have predators that attack your crops
you could have disease attack your
life's livestock there's all sorts of
possibility the other thing is that food
takes a while to grow so there's a
there's a sequence where you amass
capital by hopefully selling your
product and when you've sold your
product you then buy fertilizer and seed
for next year so you can do it again but
what happens if you don't get the price
you were hoping for and so suddenly you
see small family farms going under
because of that kind of debt structure
so what's happened in the food industry
is large mega corporations have taken
over in a sense to smooth out the risk
at least at their level so they contract
with smaller farmers a smaller farmers
sometimes go under but the large food
company has enough farms in enough
different places and the production
facilities in enough different places
that it's less risky for them and they
have the capital flow that's needed so
that they can weather literally a bad
season in some of their crops in
addition to yearly expenses farms have
long-term expenses land buildings
animals irrigation infrastructure farm
equipment I don't know if you've seen
some of those modern equipment for
harvesting crops or for planting crops
but
to be multi-million dollar machines that
are extremely sensitive and difficult to
manage but incredibly productive when
they're working correctly and a major
expenditure to two farms so one of the
ways we've dealt with that the United
States has provide provided a lot of
government subsidies farm subsidies in
2009 for 15.4 billion dollars in the
United States because of the geographic
base of politics in other words you have
places like Nebraska and Iowa that have
very few people but they both put both
of those states have two senators apiece
so farming has a disproportionate impact
on the US Senate and therefore in the US
political system than in many other
places and it's created a system of
subsidies that sometimes don't relate to
the needs of the country or the food
industry for that matter urbanization
new technology and attempts to control
financial risks of farming have led to a
century-long decline in the role of
agriculture in the American economy and
this is what's most interesting to me
about the food industry agriculture as a
proportion of our gdp has decreased
dramatically over the past century in
1930 it was seven point seven percent of
the gdp which already represented a
significant significant decline now it's
left it's less than 1% of the gdp so
here we have something that is a
biological necessity everybody in this
room you're probably all thinking about
you know when this class ends what am I
going to have for dinner okay and what
you're thinking about is but is not even
one percent of the GDP of the country
most of the economic activity in the
United States has nothing to do with
food okay tell that to a teenager but
it's true yes
that's growth that's based on everything
it's based on everything it's based on
the food industry okay so let me just
let's go to this next statistic which
will give you an idea of what why this
is working this way the percentage of
workers involved in agriculture has
declined dramatically that's what this
is showing okay now you're saying are we
importing all of our food not from other
countries most of our food and the I say
still comes from the United States a
certain amount comes from Latin America
certain amount comes from from Asia but
most of it still comes to the United
States the point is in nineteen hundred
forty percent of the workers in the
United States worked in agriculture
worked in the farm in 1930 it was twenty
percent and this year it's one percent
so you see a contracting industry as a
proportion of the gross domestic product
and so it's not to say that there aren't
other there aren't people in
food-related businesses and I'm talking
about you know the agricultural side of
it and the rest of it you know has grown
a little bit in fact some of its growing
I mean certainly Starbucks has grown a
certain amount over the past few years
large-scale production as I said
provides protection from the
boom-and-bust cycle that was
characteristic of family farming demand
for food is going to continue to
increase as population increases but a
lot of market trends influence what kind
of food people eat so you know in the
1950s and 60s you saw in America a
tremendous growth in the consumption of
meat and that over the last decade that
certainly has not grown per capita the
way did in those earlier times the
challenge of financing sustainable food
then is how can farms make a profit
despite a low food prices and low
margins and difficulty in paying back
yearly investments without using
environmentally harmful methods I mean
that's one of the problems in a
challenge industry as people figure we
can lay off some of the costs on the
ecosystem and then we won't have to
worry about that and we can make our
money at the end of the year it's one of
the problems
with food industry let's talk about the
management issues because a lot of this
is management some of this technology we
do need to develop a better knowledge of
ecological impacts and a better
knowledge of what kinds of food
production processes you have less of an
impact many agricultural producers and
food producers are large organizations
they use cutting-edge techniques they
really are large corporations these all
the techniques of a modern production
facility our urban lifestyles most of
the people in the United States as you
can see don't live on farms and don't
produce their own food so we need
massive interconnected food production
and distribution systems and we have
them the the kind of distribution system
for food in New York is unbelievable
many a lot of the food comes in through
hunts point and the Bronx where it used
to be that a lot of fish would come in
through the Fulton fish market but
that's moved up to the Bronx also and
there is a there are a large number of
companies at work every night every
morning with trucks bringing food into
all the places you buy it every day it's
it's pretty impressive an organizational
challenge is that a lot of the small
organizations that participate in these
larger webs can't protect themselves so
the small family farmer or the small
landholder in India has to deal with the
Pepsi Corporation and they have to sell
some of their some of their product to
to this big company and the terms of the
relationship sometimes is unfavorable
nevertheless that's how it's that's how
it's going to happen another challenge
is actually energy because the price of
energy affects every aspect of the food
production process from farming itself
to distribution of farms of packaging
storing shipping food over long
distances refrigeration anybody here use
fresh direct to deliver food to their
apartment okay if you're ever outside in
this neighborhood and the
evening you hear something roaring it's
the fresh direct truck because they keep
the refrigerator on the freezer on at a
pretty high carbon footprint costs
wherever they go but New Yorkers don't
have cars they like to have their stuff
deliver to them we've got to figure out
ways of reorganizing some of these
networks to use a little bit less energy
but that's going to happen more when the
energy system gets more efficient not
because of the food system the food
system is going to continue to use large
inputs of energy so the question is can
corporations get smarter about their use
of water a fertilizer of pesticides can
they analyze their impacts and
incorporate those analyses into the
agricultural practices that's a lot of
organizational learning and you need to
figure out incentives for them to do
that learning and so far we're seeing
progress and I think frankly for a lot
of you that will become sustainability
professionals the food industry is going
to be looking for people to do this kind
of work because I think that it's going
to be related to them becoming
competitive because the company that can
figure out a way to use water more
efficiently and pesticide more
efficiently and fertilizer more
efficiency is going to make a lower-cost
food product because they're not going
to be wasting as much and again it goes
back to that concept I talked about when
we talk about sustainable business if
you think about all this pollution as a
waste if the plants can absorb and use
all of these resources in the in growth
then it doesn't go into the the streams
and the waterways and into the
environment more general and that can
make for a more profitable corporation
but you got to know how to do it and
it's not going to be easy to do can
small farms survive I mean one of the
interesting things is that in fact the
number of farms in the united states
increased in the beginning of the 21st
century the number of farms increased by
four percent and part of it is this
small farming growth for local green
markets and local restaurants that it's
a niche market but because the number of
farms had declined so much it could have
a big
impact on this particular statistic I
think you're going to see the same kind
of techniques of networks in
organizations happen in the food
industry even more than you've seen it
today and the reason for that is because
the price of information and the price
of communication is going down if the
price of transportation continues to go
down through the use of containerized
shipping and hopefully more fuel
efficient transport systems then you're
going to see more and more production of
food happening the same way they produce
cars the parts come from 40 different
places and the stuffs assembled in a
single place or two or three okay and so
you're going to see those same kind of
techniques i think happen in the food
industry as well so what about
government what can government do here
well first government has to play an
active role in making agriculture more
sustainable and I should say that the
traditional role of government in
agriculture is just this bringing
technology to bear on food production
the land-grant colleges all the great
state universities in America started as
land-grant colleges with a mission of
improving local farming the Extension
Service of the Department of Agriculture
sending people out into the farms with
the new technology and new techniques to
make farmers more efficient is a deep
grain tradition in the agricultural
world and so what's needed here is
adding another dimension to this RND
tradition and to this extension
tradition of sustainability we need to
develop energy efficiency standards
farms many of which are exempt many
farms are exempt from air pollution
water pollution and energy efficiency
standards and they shouldn't be this is
a residual of the farm lobby and the
power of the foreign lobby to influence
public policy in this country we need to
develop water use standards you know
water users in naug recover uses
enormous amounts of water if you could
even reduce it a little bit it would
have a tremendous impact on the fresh
water supply and we have to fund basic
research and development in agricultural
sciences that's always been happen
that's always happened in the United
States
happened in other countries it needs to
happen even more and government should
develop a set of agricultural rule rules
and regulations to manage food market
sustained sustainably the subsidies we
have in the agricultural industry need
to be changed only ten percent of the
farms are receiving sixty one percent of
government aid and so it may be that we
want to focus these subsidies in a
different way I'd like to focus them on
some of the sustainability criteria that
can make the agricultural industry less
destructive of the environment the
government also should be responsible
for addressing and limiting agricultural
reliance on non-renewable resources such
as fossil fuels emphasize wind power and
solar power and biomass and other kinds
of renewable resources one of the
biggest problems though is solution from
feedlots the places where meat is
produced are among the most polluted
places in the United States they their
pollution is worse by far than many of
the industrial facilities that have
captured our attention and this is an
emerging environmental issue and we're
going to need to pay more and more
attention to this going forward
government needs to take responsibility
for helping to develop the technologies
that allow agriculture to be sustainable
and again just as we've seen government
intervention in developing the
technologies of the internet or the
microcomputer or the cell phone needs to
focus a little bit more on the
production of food sustainably as it's
no different than any other place where
we need to advance rd rapidly so let me
conclude that we have some time for
discussion food is necessary for human
survival that's where I started it's
just like water and air food production
is becoming less familiar to the world's
urbanites more and more of us are
further and further from the production
of food in the last decade on this
planet we became an urban majority
so the the disconnect of people from
their food supply is only going to grow
over time so we need to think about
adding environmental health to the
pre-existing priorities of maximizing
profit and minimizing costs that we see
in the food industry the food industry
is one of the more sophisticated
industries in the world you know we were
in the earth and sea we work with with
Pepsi which is a i think a pretty
interesting corporation and they we were
talking once about how difficult it is
to get things like fertilizer and other
technologies into rural parts of the
world where there's limited
transportation and difficulties with
with the power for refrigeration but you
go to the smallest place the most rural
place in the world and there's going to
be a little grocery store and they're
going to have ice cold pepsi right there
in the refrigerator somehow Pepsi
manages to get their stuff there and so
what about the the NGOs that are trying
to do similar things you know what about
the places they're trying to bring
resources for a sustainable farming and
so forth so they can do it so they know
how to do it and I think we have a lot
to learn from these companies because
they do know how to do it so that's
basically what i wanted to say about
about food except one last thing i guess
i would add there is this revulsion i
would say about industrial farming and
applying technology to the growth of
food and i think people are deluding
themselves we are using this technology
right now if it wasn't for the
application of technology to farming
what Malthus said was going to happen
would have happened we would have all
starved to death by now and so we have
to get past this ideology and this
mythology frankly it's not reality-based
so with that I'd be happy to discuss any
issues yes